movement in martin luther king came back
he'd say we need another civil rights
movement built on class not race henley
louis gates movement Martin Luther King
Mahatma Gandhi Nelson Mandela you you
were meant for something greater and
it's time to share it with the world
start your movement I was recently asked
by youtuber I've been how do you define
success for me the answer is simple
success is happiness we all want to be
happy we know what happened this feels
like and we look for in our daily lives
success isn't about money it's not about
the car you drive it's not about what
you have on your resume to me if you're
happy then you're successful so how do
you stay happy this is different for
everybody but here's what makes me happy
number one freedom I need freedom to be
able to do what I want when I want any
surprise that became an entrepreneur
what I'm told what to do or restricted
what and when I can do things I get
frustrated and lose my happiness you can
make 10 million dollars per year but if
you're working 100-hour weeks and don't
have the freedom to enjoy it does that
make you successful not in my mind
number two growth I'm happy when I'm
growing I'm also not happy when I'm not
learning something new and feel like I'm
stagnating it might be a new project in
my business a new travel adventure with
my family learning new salsa dance moves
whatever the growth can come from
anywhere but if I'm stuck in the same
pattern for too long and not learning
something new I get unhappy number three
impact this to me is actually the most
important one and the least common with
most people think about when you're
happiest it's usually when you're
helping other people you build your
friend out of a tough Jam you help the
random stranger on the street you made a
customer's day with your service if I'm
not making an impact a real difference
in people's lives and I'm unhappy I'd
even give up freedom and growth to have
impact because that's the real happiness
driver for me movement if impact drives
you then the next step is building a
movement now it's not just
helping your friend or random stranger a
customer it's changing the world your
story vision and passion can change the
lives of millions of people I love
helping entrepreneurs it's in my soul
and I'll never stop but my real interest
lies in helping entrepreneurs who want
to make a powerful difference in the
world when I die I want the world to be
a better place because of the work I did
I want the same thing for you to start
your movement believe